يجد المقيمون في لندن انفسهم يستغنون
تدريجيا عن العديد من المنتجات الغذائيه
التي عندها شرائها بعضهم يستغني عن تناول
الطعام خارج المنزل بغرض التوفير فيما
يلجا اخرون الى بنوك الغذاء بسبب العجز عن
تامين ثمن الطعام
فبريطانيا تعيش ازمه تضخم من غير مسبوقه
ضربت مختلفه القطاعات اكثرها تضررا قطاع
المواد الغذائيه الذي ارتفعت اسعاره بمعدل
قياسي تجاوز احد عشر في المئه خلال اكتوبر
فقط
وتلبيه للطلب المتزايد على الغذاء تعمل
بنوك الطعام بما يفوق قدرتها خاصه مع
تراجع التبرعات وتزايدي اعداد المحتاجين
المواد الغذائيه والمواد بشكل عام
والكهرباء والغاز
نحن الان اصبحنا امام مشكله بانه الحاج
اكبر وارتفعت الاسعار وذلك تكلفه اكثر
بكثير منه ولذلك الان بدانا حتى التواصل
مع البلديه هنا المحليه بحيث انه يستطيع
ان يغد ويغطي جزء من هذا المشروع
وبحسب دراسه المحليه فان مليوني شخص في
بريطانيا الطول للتخلي عن وجبه واحده على
الاقل يوميا خلال الاشهر القليله الماضيه
بنوك الطعام من جانبها قالت انها زادت
نسبه طرود الطعام المقدمه للمحتاجين بنسبه
50% مقارنه بما قبل وباء كرونه
المرحله
ليس فقط من المشردين بل من كثير من الناس
اللي مش قادرين
يغطوا تكاليف الطعام يوميا فلذلك رفعنا
الكميه كنا نعطي بحدود الميه قبل الكورونا
الان حوالي 150 رفعناها 50 من 50% ولذلك
الطلب كبير جدا والحاجه كبيره جدا
البنوك الطعام ظاهره ازداد وجودها مع بدي
ازمه 2008 الاقتصاديه لكنها اليوم باتت
اكثر وضوحا ويوجد ما يقارب 2,500 بنك طعام
في كافه انحاء المملكه المتحده والتي من
المتوقع ان يحتاجها العديد هنا مع توقعاته
بتفرقمي ازمه غلاء المعيشه منظرها عروبه
عبد الحق العربيه